too many people today make too much
generic content too much of the same
imagine if you're a content creator that
does card tricks and you notice that
most of your audience is young males but
you want to be the biggest Act of all
time and you have Ambitions to sell out
Las Vegas in your 30s the thing you need
to do immediately is create cohorts like
40 to 46 year old moms in Chicago if you
know you were making content for 40 to
46 year old moms in Chicago with teenage
Sons the content you're going to make is
going to try to appeal to that Mom
versus the algorithm what you think is
viral or what your friends and young men
are going to like it completely changes
the starting point of the ideation of
your creative thus allowing your brand
to Broad
it